morton gets the game three start across
walker bueller remember his last start
was on three days rest so he gets a
couple of extra days this will be his
14th postseason start only blake kershaw
has made more freeman opposite field
base hit
that is a very welcome sight for atlanta
braves fans
back-to-back singles off walker bueller
and the braves with two on gets
something cooking here in the first
two clean base hits for the braves and
here comes ozzie
albee's first ball swinging that is
going to be caught in center field
rosario's off the bag and a double play
oh a costly base running mistake
eddie rosario was already on his way to
third
and gavin lux he is an inexperienced
center fielder but he might have deeped
him a little bit he makes the catch and
gets the double play charlie morton last
11 starts for charlie on the road era
2.55 hasn't allowed a home run in that
time now corey seeger who's been
relatively quiet so far in the post
season seven for 32
one ball two strikes zieger the fly ball
to center field it's deep it's on its
way and it is gone
corey seeger a two-run home run
and just like that
two batters into the game as was the
case on sunday the dodgers take a two to
nothing lead
guys corey seeger now 13 postseason
homers that ties in with justin turner
for the most postseason homers in dodger
franchise history whatever the book the
braves have on seeger in the postseason
turner the batting champion this year
328 hitter
led the majors in batting average
a key pickup for the dodgers there goes
bets
throw down to second base high and off
the glove of all these he was trying to
make a quick catch and tag
and it's another stolen base mookie bets
is in there
that's now 13 consecutive successful
steals
runner at first one out and riley in the
air center field deep glasses on for
lots he's at the wall and he missed it
he missed it freeman now on his way to
third riley in the second base
you could see the sun was eating him up
and the braves get a big break it's now
second and third with one out well sun
may have been a factor
but one of the uh the problems you have
with glo with guck's
lux in center field
is the fact he hasn't been there a whole
lot to provide with the sun
so now jack could tie it with a base hit
three minute third reilly at second and
the first big break of the ball game for
the braves
[Applause]
wow
see bueller shaking his head not shaking
your head as you missed it
you missed that pitch roberts knows it
too
he connects and drives one into right
field for a base hit freeman will score
they'll give riley a stop sign and the
braves are on the board on an rbi single
from jack peterson
it's 2-1 in favor of the dodgers
or the braves have him cornered now with
one down trailing by one run
jack peterson making the most of an
opportunity after what should have been
a strike three call
got one back there now duval broken bad
that's going to fall a base hit this
game is all tied up as adam duvall
an rbi single
2-2 game duvall's first rbi of the
postseason
and it ties the game in the fourth
four hits in the inning three
consecutive
[Music]
they are loaded up here
dansby swanson with one away
[Applause]
bueller deals it and that is off the
glove of seeger one run in for sure
peterson and now washington holds duvall
back he goes
and the normally aggressive ron
washington is being conservative here
sensing a big inning for atlanta
the braves take the lead three to two on
a dansby swanson single
three balls no strikes pitch on the way
ball four four two atlanta and buehler's
screaming at jerry meals
and here comes dave roberts
i mean roberts was out of the dugout
before
smith even threw the ball back
vezia
to freeman
first pitch
shallow left sprinting in is taylor to
make the catch and that will end the
inning a little history here duvall back
in august against victor homer here
toddler stadium
and that ball's in the air left center
going to get down a base hit albies will
score turning and heading to third is
riley
and adam duvall a big hit for atlanta
back-to-back hat bats he drives in runs
it is five to two braves in the fifth
inning
charlie morton
a family man
his wife and four kids
all in their morton jerseys
coming from tampa his hometown to
watch dad pitch
on the ground got a chance to turn two
here it'll be albie's by himself and a
double play and charlie morton
on the ropes early
has delivered five strong innings for
atlanta
two balls two strikes bases empty one
down
matsix set
two two on the way
have a seat swung on and missed strike
three
two quick outs for tyler madsen
awaits the 2-2 it's from matship sia
swung on and missed
that time he fan him with a slider
and turner in frustration just drops the
bat drops the helmet drops the batting
gloves yeah some fans heading for the
exits here not hopeful
five to two the braves lead the dodgers
here in game three the braves have a 2-0
series lead
alby's in the air right center field
long way to go taylor closes makes the
play
nice catch
pollock up the middle that is through a
base hit
a big hit for aj
with two strikes
and now the dodgers will bring the tying
run to the plate
cody bellinger will bat
representing the tying run here in the
eighth inning he's been hitting the ball
as hard as anybody in the postseason one
ball two strikes
now the pitch to bellinger
and a fly ball to right center field
it's well hit and it is gone a three-run
home run for bellinger we've got a new
game
it's tied at five
on a one-two pitch
it out
on a pitch charlie
that may have been a ball a fastball and
it was probably high and out of this
frank zone instead it was high and out
of the ballpark
and it's a new game
bellinger's home run traveled 399
feet
and now this crowd of 51 000 is up
here's taylor base head left field
chris taylor jumping on the first pitch
the dodgers
with three runs in
now a man on
see if taylor's on the move shift is on
there he goes the pitch and it's inside
throw the second the tag safe
a stolen base for taylor
thinking about all those fans at
greatest rally cap in the world right
there
seeger on deck bench with a fly ball to
right
and it drops in for a base hit it's
gonna roll to the wall
taylor scores bets is it second base the
dodgers with four in the eighth now lead
the braves six to five
we can attest to the fact that 50 000
plus
can physically move this stadium
it is bouncy
albed an aggressive hitter in this type
of count chavez trying to go away and
that ball runs right back over the
middle of plate bets having a great
series on base three out of the four
times today peterson thought he had a
line on it he did it first until it just
kept going like you said
that's why kenley janssen on the mound
the dodgers have the lead now in the
ninth and the closer is on to face
austin reilly
jensen's 2-2 and a cold strike three
two and two to peterson here's the pitch
straight through there two out
95 that was the fourth semen
can he strike out the side and in the
game here's a 2-2 a swing out of this he
struck him out he strikes out the side
and the ball game is over and the
dodgers come off the deck
to win game three nicola vulture organic
seltzer as real as it tastes